JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
I've got a nice exercise here
on Stokes' Theorem for you.
Now this problem is
a little bit more
sophisticated than
a lot of problems
we've been doing in recitation.
So it requires a little bit
more thought, and it also
involves more mathematical
sophistication.
So we're doing a clever kind
of proof here that I like.
So hopefully you'll
like this one.
It's a little bit in a different
style than some of the ones
we've done.
So I think I need to talk
about it a little bit before we
get started.
So let's let F be
the field [x,  y, z].
So this is our radial field that
we've seen a lot in recitation.
So what I'd like
you to do is prove
that this field is not the
curl of any field G. All right.
So I'd like you to
show that there's
no field G such that F is
equal to the curl of G.
Now, rather than just
saying that to you
and letting you run
off, I have a suggestion
for an interesting way
you could go about this.
And this interesting way is
going to use Stokes' Theorem.
So what I'd like you to do
is a proof by contradiction.
OK, so what you're
going to do is
you're going to assume
that F is a curl.
OK?
So you're going to
assume that there
is some G such that F is
curl G. And then you're
going to use that to get
a ridiculous conclusion.
So you're going to
start with that premise,
and you're going to end
up with a contradiction.
So these two arrows
colliding into each other
is a symbol that mathematicians
use for a contradiction.
So you're going to
start from this premise,
and you're going to
reach a contradiction.
And what that's going to
show is that your premise
couldn't be right.
Yeah?
Because if you start
from a true premise,
well then all your conclusions
should be true as well.
So if you reach a
false conclusion,
then you must have
had a false premise.
So what you're going
to do is you're
going to take a sphere of
radius b centered at the origin.
And a curve C on the sphere.
You know, a simple,
closed curve.
So assuming that F is this curl
of G, what I'd like you to do
is use Stokes'
Theorem to interpret
the line integral of G dot dr
over C in two different ways.
OK?
And interpreting this line
integral in two different ways,
you're going to reach
a contradiction,
and that will show that
F really isn't a curl.
So that's what I'd
like you to do.
So why don't you
pause the video,
go ahead and see if you can
work that out, come back,
and we'll talk
about it together.
I hope you enjoyed
working on this problem.
Let's get started on it.
So as I was saying before we
started, what we're going to do
is we're looking for a
proof by contradiction.
So as the problem says, we're
going to start with a sphere.
And I'm going to
take this curve C--
some simply connected closed
curve that's going to go around
the back of the sphere, and
it's going to be oriented
one way or the
other-- and it's going
to divide this sphere
into two pieces.
So there's the one cap
on one side of it, S_1.
And then there's-- whatever the
other piece on the other side
of it is, S_2.
OK.
And so what we're going to
do is we're going to think
about, what is
this line integral?
OK.
So this is our curve
C here on the sphere.
So the integral
over C of G dot dr.
So this is what the problem
suggests we think about.
So this is a line
integral of a field dot dr
over the boundary of a surface.
Well, actually, it's the
boundary of two surfaces.
Right?
C is the boundary of S1,
and C-- if we orient it
the other way-- is the
boundary of S_2, when
we orient them both outwards.
OK, so what is this?
So Stokes' Theorem
tells us something
about this line integral.
So let's first think about
this as the top cap-- that
cap S1-- with boundary
C oriented so that they
agree with each other.
So the normal is
outwards on the sphere,
and C is proceeding
in the direction
that I've drawn the arrow here.
Well, in that
circumstance, we have
that the integral around C of
G dot dr, by Stokes' Theorem,
is equal to the surface integral
over S_1 of curl of G dot
n with respect to surface area.
Right?
So this is just Stokes' Theorem.
Stokes' Theorem says
the line integral
of G around the boundary
curve is equal to the surface
integral of the curl
of G over the region,
provided all of our
orientations are correct.
OK.
Well, we know though
what curl of G
is, because by assumption,
F is equal to curl of G. OK,
so this is equal to the surface
integral over S1 of F dot n dS.
So in the first step,
we use Stokes' Theorem.
In the second step,
we use our assumption
that curl G is equal
to F. Well, now what?
But we know what F is.
Right?
F is this radial
field [x, y,  z].
So F and n are pointing
in the same direction.
They're parallel to each
other. n is a unit vector,
so this is just the
length of F. This F dot
n is just the length
of F. And since we're
on a sphere of radius
b, this is just b.
OK, so the integrand is just b.
So this is the
integral over S_1 of b
dS, which is b times
the area of S_1.
OK.
One thing I'd like you to notice
is that in particular, this
is a positive number.
b is positive and
the area is positive.
OK.
So that's our first
interpretation.
So we took our field G
that we suppose exists,
and we integrate it
around this curve C,
and we apply Stokes'
Theorem, and then
the fact that we
know what F is means
that we know what F dot n is,
and so that makes our surface
integral very easy to compute.
And it turns out to be b
times the area of S, which,
I just happened to notice,
is a positive number.
OK.
Well, now we can
do the same trick
on the other half of the sphere.
Right?
So we just did the top cap here.
We did S_1.
So now we have the
bottom cap, or whatever.
All the rest of the sphere, S_2.
OK.
So we can also get that the
integral over C of G dot dr,
we can interpret it in
terms of Stokes' Theorem.
But notice then
that C-- we still
want to use the same normal.
We like outwards
pointing normals.
So we're going to have to
orient C the other way in order
to make Stokes'
Theorem make sense.
So let's walk over here where
we have some empty board space.
So we want to orient
C the other way.
So in other words, we're
going to take the negative
of this line integral.
So it's minus G
dot dr. And if we
apply Stokes' Theorem to
this line integral-- so this
is the same line integral, but
with the opposite orientation
on C and so with the opposite
sign-- by Stokes' Theorem,
this is equal to the integral
over S_2 of the curl of G
dot n dS.
And so the way I've set
this up, this is still
my outward-pointing normal.
OK.
But again, we can
use our assumption
and we can get curl
of G is equal to F,
because we're assuming
that G has this property.
So this is equal to
the integral over S_2
of F dot n with respect
to surface area.
And again, n is the
outward-pointing normal,
and F is parallel to it.
So this dot product
is just the length
of F. The outward
pointing unit normal.
So this is just the
length of F, which is b.
So this is equal to b
times the area of S_2,
which is also positive.
So what have we just shown?
Well, we started
from the assumption
that there exists a G such
that F is the curl of G.
And starting from
that assumption--
let's look-- we showed that
the line integral around C of G
dot dr is equal to
some positive number.
And we also showed, over
here, that the negative
of the line integral
of G around C
is equal to some
positive number.
Well, this is clearly absurd.
That can't be true.
So starting from our assumption
that F was the curl of G--
that there is a G such
the F is the curl of G--
we reached an absurd conclusion.
We reached a conclusion
that the same number
is both positive and negative.
But that can't happen.
So that means our
premise had to be false.
OK.
So this is a contradiction.
So our assumption is false.
And our assumption
was-- that we used
to get this whole thing
started-- that F was
the curl of some G. All right.
So what have we shown?
So we used a nice argument
here with Stokes' Theorem
in order to show that
certain fields aren't
the curl of other fields.
So Stokes' Theorem limits
the kind of fields that
can be curls of other fields.
Now perhaps, you may have
thought of other theorems
that you can use that also
limit what sorts of fields
can be curls.
And so there are other ways
to reach this true conclusion
that our field F-- whose
components are x, y, and z--
is not the curl of any field.
This isn't the only way
to reach that conclusion.
But this is a nice way that
shows that Stokes' Theorem puts
some limitations on what fields
can behave like if they're
going to be curls.
I'll stop there.